يجتمع وزراء دفاع الاوروبيون اليوم في
العاصمه السويديه ستوكهولم لمراقبه عده
ملفات على راسها اوكرانيا ومن المتوقع ان
يعطي الوزراء الضوء الاخضر لخطه ارسال
المزيد من الذخيره الى كييف من ستوكهولم
ينضم الينا الان وزير الدفاع السلوفاكي
جروسلاف ناد نرحب بك
سيد جرس لاف بدايه مدى تامل سلوفاكيا من
هذا الاجتماع الاوروبي
حضرنا اليوم هنا الى السويد بغيت
مناقشه
السبل التي من شانها ان نوفر من خلالها
مساعدات اضافيه لاوكرانيا لمواجهه العدوان
الروسي وايضا ايجاد حلول في اسرع وقت ممكن
مع وزراء الدفاع وذلك لكي نقدم المعدات او
الذخيره لاوكرانيا لكي يستطيعوا الدفاع عن
انفسهم هذا وقت مهم جدا لهم لكي يدافعوا
عن انفسهم وسوف نجد سبلا لكي نقدم هذه
المساعده لهم لكي يدافع عن انفسهم وذلك في
اسرع وقت ممكن
في الجبهه الشرقيه لحلف الناتو الذي يمكن
ان تتم مناقشته ضمن هذا اللقاء او هذا
الاجتماع
[موسيقى]
يه
نحن من الدول التي تجاور اوكرانيا وفي
الجانب الشرقي من النيتو هذا العدوان
الروسي له اثار عظيمه على سلوفاكيا فيما
يتعلق بتدفق اللاجئين
وايضا له اثاره الاقتصاديه ولكن ايضا
بالاضافه الى ذلك له اثاره الدفاعيه لذلك
فنحن نقوم بالتجهيز
كجزء من الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا كجزء من
النيتو لكي نناقش هذه السياسات الدفاعيه
التي تساعدنا للدفاع عن انفسنا فنحن ارض
انيته ونحن لدينا مجموعات قتاليه متعدده
موجوده في سلوفاكيا ومنتشره كما اننا نقوم
ايضا
بالاستثمار في البنيه التحتيه وفي المعدات
ايضا لكي نزيد قدراتنا الدفاعيه هذا الامر
ايضا يناقش على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وعلى مستوى النيتو وهناك امر اخر وهو اننا
اضافه الى رومانيا وبولندا
نقوم بجهود مهمه لدعم الدول الجديده في
النيتو في
الجهود التي من شانها ان تقدم الدعم اكثر
واكثر لاوكرانيا لما يتعلق بالدعم المخصص
لاوكرانيا والذي اشرت اليه قبل قليل
تحديدا سلوفاكيا ما الذي ستقدمه من دعم
عسكري لاوكرانيا ان كان ما يتعلق بالذخيره
او بغيرها
الان قمنا بتقديم عشره حزم من الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا بالاضافه الى عملنا
بشان خيارات وحلول اخرى الان نحن نقوم
بمناقشه انظمه الدفاع الجويه والتي من
شانها ان تساعدهم للدفاع انفسهم ضد
الهجمات السابقين من روسيا وايضا امكانيه
تقديم تبرعات
وعشرين وقمنا ايضا بطلب اف 16 ايضا وسوف
نقدمها ونوفرها في اسرع وقت ممكن
لاوكرانيا لذلك لدينا حيز هنا لكي نقوم
بمناقشه هذه القضاء المتعلقه بمج تسعه
وعشرين وسوف نوفرها لاوكرانيا بعد اتمام
النقاشات في الاسابيع القليله القادمه
ماذا عن دور الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى
المشاركه في اجتماع
لدعم اوكرانيا ماذا تامل وماذا تتوقع
سلوفاكيا من هم
الكثير من الدول والبلدان التي تحاول ان
تجد الحلول المناسبه لمساعده اوكرانيا هنا
في النقاشات الدائره في الاتحاد الاوروبي
دول البلطيق وبولندا ودول اخرى ايضا تحاول
ان تضع مقترحات وحلول
لعمليه الشراء المشترك للذخائر هذا الامر
سيتم نقاشه اليوم وسوف نجده حلولا لكي
نقوم كلنا معا بالحصول والاستحواذ والشراء
الذخائر المناسبه وان نقدمها لاوكرانيا
والتي تحتاجها اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها
ضد العدوان الروسي هناك ايضا مجالات اخرى
حيث نقوم بمناقشتها على مستوى الاتحاد
الاوروبي سلوفاكيا الان داعمه لهذه
المبادرات كلها وسوف نفعل كل ما بوسعنا
لكي
نحصل الاجماع من كل هذه الدول للقيام بهذه
الجود وانني متفائل جدا مدى التوافق في
هذا الملف او في هذا الاطار مدى الاجماع
بين هذه الدول المجتمعه فيما يتعلق بالدعم
العسكري
نعم ان هناك اجماع قائما ومعظم الدول
ايضا تدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
وهناك بعض الدول عددها محدود جدا لا تقدم
الدعم العسكري ولكنها لا تقوم
بتفريقه هذا الاجماع
وهم انفسهم
عددهم قليل جدا ومحدود اما الاغلبيه
العظمى فهي جزء لا يتجزا من منتدى رمشتاين
لتقديم المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا في
هذا الاطار وفيها 60 عضو في الدول من اسيا
الى امريكا الجنوبيه
شكرا جزيلا لك الوزير الدفاع سلوكي جرس
لاف نات